-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-And finally, New Rule.
Now that I've heard
author Michael Lewis say
about his latest subject
crypto crasher,
Sam Bankman-Fried,
that... (READS PROMPT)
-(SMACKS LIPS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I say we finally start
seriously looking at what phones
are doing to people's brains.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Wow.
And not just phones,
there has been a perfect storm
of events in recent years
that has led the surgeon general
of the United States
to issue an advisory that
America is suffering from...
(READS PROMPT)
What Matt Gaetz calls
"another day at work."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
And this is not just in America,
Japan and the UK
have actually appointed
a cabinet level position
for Minister for Loneliness...
because the studies and the data
from around the world
show that
the health consequences
of so many people
feeling so isolated
are staggering.
Skyrocketing rates of stroke,
heart disease, premature death.
It's just become too easy
to isolate now.
We've got our phones
and our gadgets to distract
from having
an actual conversation.
Amazon to deliver
instead of going to a store.
Grubhub instead of going
to a restaurant.
Movies streaming on TV
instead of going to a theater.
And even when we do go out,
the earbuds stay in.
(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
We can't even do
casual chitchat anymore.
Remember when you'd roll
through the checkout line
with a six-pack
and a box of condoms. (SNICKERS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
You know.
You'd have a little moment
with the checker
where he'd be like...
"Heh.
Somebody's having a party, huh?"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
But there are no high fives
at the self-checkout.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
We've traded going out
with people we like
for going on Facebook
to get likes.
Has anything ever been
more misnamed than social media?
It's done more
to kill being social
-than the pocket protector.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
It should be called,
"Antisocial media."
And then AI came along
and made it even worse.
Do you know a 19-year-old
from Southampton, England
recently breached the walls
of Windsor Castle
in an attempt
to assassinate the Queen
because
his AI chatbot girlfriend
told him it would impress her?
Yes,
there's an AI Jodie Foster now.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING,
APPLAUDING)
(SCOFFS)
And the idea
that your "girlfriend"
now is just a voice
in your phone
just like in that movie, Her,
is no longer science fiction.
There's one bot chick
on the market called "Replika"
and she has two million users,
and boy is she gonna be
in trouble
when her boyfriends find out
she's seeing
two million other guys.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING,
CHEERING)
Everybody keeps saying
how AI is coming for your job,
and it may well be,
but it's also coming
for your boyfriend.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(SMACKS LIPS)
Yuval Harari asked the question
about the future...
(READS PROMPT)
I don't know but it sounds like
it'll be a profitable world
for the makers of Jergens.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING,
CHEERING)
And if the technology
wasn't making the problem
bad enough,
we also have a media
that is built on ginning up fear
and hostility, and convincing us
no place is ever really safe.
Poor Britney Spears
can't even dance in her own home
-without a couple of knives.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Whoo!
We've become like that old lady
from The Twilight Zone episode
who hides behind closed doors
because she thinks
death is trying to get in.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But here's the irony
in real life,
what's killing you
may well be you staying inside.
The overreaction
to the COVID pandemic
may turn out to be more damaging
than the disease itself.
The strategy
of social distancing
and staying home to work,
and staying home from school
all for very long periods
of time
made us into different people.
Safetyism became
a political identity,
and now some people never want
to go back to work
or school or Venezuela.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING,
APPLAUDING)
Too many people
got used to saying,
"No, I can't make it
to your birthday party.
Not for any compelling reason,
just for the sake
of ultimate safety."
Well, we're just now starting
to tally the collateral damage
from ultimate safety,
from long lockdowns
and creating
four-year-old germaphobes,
and they include
erasing two decades of progress
in math and reading.
School absenteeism
as the new normal.
An all-time drug high
and overdoses and murders.
Huge increases in obesity
and depression
and the atrophying
of social skills
that lead to it.
You know what else
went off the charts
the last couple of years?
Car crashes.
They couldn't figure out why.
You know what they came up with?
People's heads
are just so scrambled,
and they're so full
of pent-up rage
from being locked up
and the kids home all the time,
and my stupid fucking husband.
So, they just got in the car
and drove like a maniac,
-and took it out on the road.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
-So... (CHUCKLES)
So, to quote every mother
since the dawn of time,
for fuck's sake,
go play outside.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, CHEERING,
APPLAUDING)
Huh?
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
I know, I know.
Outside is full of flashers
and rusty nails
and germs and sharks
and stranger danger.
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
-But your mother was right,
it's actually worse
to stay cooped up.
Magazine surveys
like to ask the question,
"How would you like to die?"
My answer is, "Anything
except going unnoticed
until the neighbors complain
about the smell."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING,
CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Twenty years ago, the show
that defined the Zeitgeist
was called Friends.
Today, it's Naked and Afraid.